it's important to be uh telling stories
that I'm passionate about I think
passion is something that that comes
through
readily and if you're passionate about
what you're sharing
that does a lot of the heavy lifting
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders I'm really
excited to share with you today the
story of Josh Tyson the co-author of the
Wall Street Journal business bestseller
age of invisible machines he's also
director of Storytelling at One reach Ai
and the co-host of n9k a podcast from
the future
thank you
it's really exciting to be here yeah the
excitement is on we're going to be
talking about the storytelling
conversational AI a bunch of other
things in between and a storytelling and
conversational AI are two things that
I'm particularly interested in and
passionate about so this is going to be
a fun conversation uh tell me a little
bit about yourself you know how did you
even get into the world of of
Storytelling for instance what what does
that even mean storytelling
well that's a good question
um to me I think it just stemmed from
knowing from pretty young age
that if I was storytelling if I was
telling stories that I'd be happy I
pursued a journalism degree
not so much envisioning being a reporter
but really just knowing that if I had
that Foundation I could I could use that
to
to leverage to to just be telling
stories at all times uh I was early on
kind of drawn to the Gonzo kind of like
Joan Didion approach to journalism where
you're drawing directly from your own
experiences and you you often become a
part of the story uh I kind of loved
being an active Observer and I realized
that
early on I was seeking out jobs not so
much because they fit
uh my idea of of what a professional
career should be but because they would
expose me to really interesting
situations and people
um for a long time I was a bus driver
for a Senior Citizen Center I kind of
worked on a split shift so I would pick
a lot of people up in the morning and
I'd bring them to the center where
they'd spend time
um it was affiliated with the Counseling
Center so there was some therapy going
on and then in the afternoon I'd take
them home and just having that time
to engage with older adults who'd had
just really interesting experiences and
I just got focused time to sit and chat
with them and get to know them and then
I was working on a split shift so I was
able to spend my days pursuing freelance
writing stuff just
working as a movie critic an art critic
just kind of covering local news and
events and things that always brought me
a lot of joy and uh
I'd also work for a time as a valet
which was an interesting experience as I
was just looking for other gigs I ended
up working as a valet for a while and
that was a position where you are sort
of invisible
um people kind of ignore the valet who
Parks their car
um and and I kind of thought that was
really interesting I liked that I liked
that I could just sit and observe and
and see interactions between people
where they didn't really realize I was
there so it's kind of Next Level fly on
the wall sort of situation
um
balance between
you know you're talking about the power
storytelling and being it you you even
said the active active Observer and then
transitioning towards you know the the
experience of being invisible yet being
invisible in a in an environment in
which you are already trained to
appreciate to the activeness of being a
part of a situation and experiencing it
yeah yeah and you know I I spent a lot
of my life uh skateboarding
and early on when I started
skateboarding it was sort of an outsider
activity there weren't a lot of skate
parks in the world and so my friends and
I would just skate around downtown and
when we rolled up to
you know buildings and Architectural
features we had a totally different idea
of of what those could be used for and
and they were quite different to us than
they were to the people who were kind of
bustling by and not paying as much
attention uh and I I think that also fit
into because skaters I think
derogatorily or sometimes or at least
back then we would get called lurkers a
lot
which I think was meant to be an insult
but we really kind of wore it as a badge
because we were again it was sort of
that valet situation where we were
unwanted and invisible in a way but we
we really
were embedded and we're seeing things on
on a different level I think than than
maybe other people and so that always
felt really advantageous to me and
skateboarding uh walking
I've always done a lot of walking I've
always done a lot of yoga and those
things
um to me feel integral to what I do
professionally because
to me they're they're meditative
activities and I'm able to really
process a lot of ideas uh as I'm just
going on walks or skating around or
stretching like that's that's actually a
really important time for me to
germinate new ideas
uh if I'm trying to digest them just on
my own or if I'm trying to synthesize
them into writing uh that's actually a
really
important part of of my process so do
you do you um do you take advantage of
of this realization for you know when
you need when you feel like you you have
an idea coming in you need to now go and
explore it or do you actively trigger
yourself into a more creative or
generative mindset through these
activities because I think that what
you're touching on you know this this
concept of a Creator create creators or
writer's block right which is a pretty
common phenomenon maybe you can tell me
more about that but but it sounds like
you sort of have your own method of
being able to generate your own
activation of neural your own neural
Activation so that you can put yourself
in a state of flow where you can let
ideas come in
absolutely uh I think biologically
exercises probably just plays a part in
that yeah moving your body I think is is
good for your your mind regardless and I
think gets your whole body kind of
working as a
as an effective ecosystem I suppose uh
but for me yeah that's a big part of
of I don't I guess sometimes I'll I'll
use it to jump start creativity
sometimes I feel like I'm doing those
things actively just to maintain a level
of creativity or openness that I I feel
is important to to maintain as
especially as I'm working on bigger
projects and things
awesome okay so so tell me a little bit
about storytelling you know for and I'd
love to start from the the impact of
Storytelling how how can we
how can we try and you know quantify or
even just explain what what an impact
the story can have and where why is why
storytelling important
well storytelling is interesting to me
um because
it almost feels biological in a way I
feel like uh humans
we have a need to have stories told to
us that I think goes beyond uh
you know a desire of the mind
um I and if you notice like a lot of
times I don't know if you've read uh
what's the Joseph Campbell work I think
it's called a hero with a thousand faces
but the central idea there is that we
kind of tell the same stories over and
over again throughout history
uh you know you'll you'll introduce new
characters and new details and settings
and things like that but a lot of times
that hero's journey uh is cut is a is a
recurring theme and and there's
variations on that that recur throughout
literature and throughout history and so
I think
when you think about storytelling in
that way that you're not just
telling a story
I mean you can tell a story for your own
personal game but when you think of it
more as an opportunity to connect
with a broad audience or with other
people on this very deep
subconscious level that
um we don't always think of actively but
that is very much there
I think being able to to tap into that
and having the ability
and it's not always easy I've probably
failed as many times as I've succeeded
but to really be able to tell a
compelling story and to
have users or readers feel like they're
a part of it
they're they're relating to it on a
deeper level than just here's me
explaining something to you
um I think as you know I've done a lot
of creative writing I've done a lot of
like I mentioned kind of like Gonzo
style journalism where I've just written
about my own experiences for
different magazines skateboarding
magazines small independent newspapers
that kind of thing
um but as I started moving more into
writing about technical things and
Technology
I realized that it was still really
important to be able to connect with
people on a on a basic level that they
were really going to be a lot more open
to learning these new ideas and to
grappling with very complex ideas
if they if you could give them the sense
that it was a journey that they were
taking with you as the Storyteller that
that you're helping them you're not so
much telling them that this is how it is
you're you're guiding them and letting
them come to these realizations
in their own minds as well and I think
that's when people really internalize
information is is when they feel
connected to the story behind it and
ultimately if they can feel like they're
a part of that story even if it's
something
that might seem dry and Technical
there's there's always an opportunity to
connect on a deeper level through
storytelling
yeah I mean I think this whole concept
of uh alignment and how do we get how do
we form meaningful relationships and
Partnerships that what you're touching
on is how do we how do we and I love how
you mentioned that you know there's one
thing to tell a story that's you know
that that's interesting and that's that
but but then how do we get the the
person who we're telling the story to to
connect and feel a part of the story so
that they really are connecting to it I
think that's really a a really
interesting concept I'd love to you know
learn from you a little bit on on
effective storytelling you're you are
director of Storytelling at One reach AI
so I'd love to soon you know transition
a little bit to understanding One reach
Ai and and how storytelling is
Incorporated in the world of
conversational AI but but let's even
just start with storytelling you know
effective storytelling things that I
should be keeping in mind and I'm
guessing that ni and I do believe this
that this isn't a really important skill
regardless of what you do because of the
way we humans are right
yeah uh sometimes I feel like
storytelling is a bit like acting in a
way
um yeah there are some people that just
seem to kind of know how to do it and
they can't they can't always explain why
they're able to do it and it's and it's
also kind of difficult to teach that's
not to say that you can't learn to be a
good Storyteller
um I mean the Joseph Campbell example
kind of illustrates that there are
formulas that you can follow
um and certain story arcs that seem to
connect with people universally so I
think if you're building a message and
and you think about these archetypes you
have a much better chance
of connecting
um and then but there is sort of that
like I don't know if it's like a soft
science but there's that that bit of it
that's sort of indefinable
in a way I I feel like I've I've written
a lot over the course of my career and
that is one of the things that's hardest
to explain to people is like how I'm
able to do it
um but I think
it's important obviously
to me anyway to to be uh telling stories
that I'm passionate about I think
passion is something that that comes
through
readily and if you're passionate about
what you're sharing
that does a lot of the heavy lifting
and then also
trying to find out is it is that so when
you say passion because because I do
find that as well when you say to be
passionate about something is that you
know is that a you know in the way that
I are does that come across in my
articulation and my tone of voice in the
the word choice that I use where do you
find articulation or passion to Be an
Effective trait within storytelling
yeah
um I think of it almost as the engine of
Storytelling I guess uh if I'm if I'm
spending too much time worrying about if
I'm being articulate
uh I can lose focus on that drive of
like this is
I I think with storytelling
passion is really what carries it
forward a lot of the times and if you
get hung up thinking about
specific elements of the story you're
trying to tell sometimes that can be
that can sideline you so obviously it's
it's a balance too of of being well
prepared
um for me anyway if I if I'm preparing
to tell a story or to share information
uh I don't really like to script it
what I like to do is just kind of have
bullets and have an arc in mind I think
when I'm putting together presentations
or
articles or even like longer things like
books I'm always thinking about the Arc
of the story
I'm not necessarily thinking of it as
distinctly as the hero's journey
but maybe there are elements of that in
there
to where
people sense that there's conflict and
resolution
throughout a story even if it's just a
story about how to use a piece of
technology
there are ways that you can
Infuse those stories with very human
elements
and I I think that's a great way to
connect with people especially when
you're the more technical things get the
harder it can become to find ways to to
humanize it
but I feel like that's a key piece if
people feel connected to something
uh they're gonna have a much better
chance of understanding it using it
themselves and I think that's where that
passion comes through you can almost uh
give them your passion yeah through an
effective story told well right going
back again to to connectedness and so
tell me a little bit about one reach AI
conversational Ai and the book that you
wrote
yeah
um
so it that that Journey actually
probably began about 10 years ago which
is kind of interesting I uh I started
working as a managing editor for ux
magazine
uh which I think at the time and still
is is sort of the preeminent online
publication for experienced designers
it's sort of a community Hub as well
um and I came to that role with very
little
knowledge about experience designer
technology I just had a lot of knowledge
about how to publish magazines and
online magazines
but what really struck me right away was
this idea of Designing experiences the
well-designed experiences to me felt
like these Vivid living actualized
stories
and I felt like a lot of the work that
experienced designers were doing uh
required a lot of the same skills that I
would use as a Storyteller being able to
kind of put myself in other people's
shoes
trying to adopt a variety of variety of
viewpoints which again is where that
that art of uh lurking I guess kind of
came in handy
um and so at the time uh Rob Wilson who
I who I co-authored age invisible
machines with uh he's he owns ux
magazine
um and he and I didn't have a lot of
contact back in those days he very busy
he was uh
onereach.ai didn't exist at the time but
um he was kind of dividing his time
between Denver and Kiev where we have uh
Hub office now for one reach AI
um so
I I left you a magazine and then years
later it was actually during the
pandemic I I was kind of revisiting my
old list of clients and friends
um because my wife and I we at the time
I was helping her she's a hair stylist
and we had a small hair salon so I was
helping her run day-to-day stuff when
the pandemic hit and so we closed up
shop
and then I reached out uh to a good
friend Elias Parker
who uh was sort of the executive
producer I guess you'd say on on our
book and he was working on a white paper
that was
um explaining a lot of Rob's thoughts
and I started helping him with that
trying to figure out how I could apply
storytelling to it essentially
and it was going well and then it kind
of turned into a thing where I was
having two to three hour calls with Rob
and Elias
uh one or two times a week just about
the concepts in the white paper and it
just kept mushrooming the white paper
all of a sudden was way too big to be a
white paper and we started thinking of
things in terms of chapters in a book
um so
yeah it was an amazing experience to
have I felt incredibly fortunate to
reconnect with these wonderful people
that I'd worked with before and and to
be able to work on a very exciting
project like this and uh
you know around that same time One reach
like well Rob
I can back up a little Rob
has a pretty long and prestigious career
in experience design he actually I would
say that germ was seeded back when he
was he worked in sound design uh for
Warner Brothers the movie studio many
years ago and it was around the time
that uh the movie studios were
transitioning from analog to digital
uh and he was someone who understood
technology and he could see that if
if all of a sudden they were hiring
sound and film editors just based on
their ability to use a computer
they were going to lose all this accrued
wisdom
um that he was surrounded you know he
was working with editors who'd been in
the game for like 50 years and stuff and
he saw that as unacceptable right you
don't want to lose there's there's a
very real Rhythm and Nuance to editing
film in it and it actually I think comes
from the physical act of cutting it and
so
his response uh was to kind of design
one of the first digital film editing
platforms and it it mimicked the
the physical machine that you would use
to edit film and so that enabled the Old
Guard editors to understand how to use
this new technology but then also to
pass along those experiences and that
knowledge of like how you edit film and
that you know there's there's
distinct stuff that's very hard to learn
unless you do it Hands-On and so
I think that kind of seated for him this
idea that
he needed to do whatever he could moving
forward to make sure that the gap
between people and Technology
continued to narrow he didn't want it to
widen and so he went on to become he
found an effective UI which was one of
the first experienced design agencies
um
and he actually co-authored a book
called effective UI that was kind of
about a lot of the things that that they
worked on there and
so
he was he was devoted in a way to to
making technology more accessible to
people and one of the things that he
recognized
quickly was that conversational
experiences with technology
were some of the uniformly some of the
worst experiences people had with
technology
and so that kind of became his passion
was was trying to figure out how to
improve that
and so
really ux magazine and uh this book age
of invisible machines and one reach AI
or dot AI are all kind of pillars
uh in a in a broader goal uh that that I
feel like I guess I now share with him
to to make sure that technology isn't
leaving people behind
you know through ux magazine it's about
sharing
the insights that experienced designers
have in terms of like making technology
relevant and useful for people uh the
book was really just an effort to share
all the things Rob's learned in the 20
years he spent working on conversational
AI he's he's fairly unique for a founder
and CEO in that he he doesn't like to be
in the spotlight
he's he's very humble and unassuming and
he's he's always quite willing to get on
the phone and explain the things he's
learned about conversational AI even if
it's
to a direct competitor he he's really
quite giving of his his time and
knowledge but he only has so much time
in his day right for Zoom calls with
competitors so so this book uh really
became a vehicle for him to share
all the many things he's learned uh
working in conversational eye with with
the team he's assembled at One reach AI
uh and around the time
that the book was really coming together
onereach dot AI uh scored highest on um
I want to get the title right here it's
a Gartner report but it's Gartner's
inaugural 2022 uh critical capabilities
for conversational AI Enterprise
platforms report
which is a real mouthful but essentially
uh you know all for many years
onereach.a is AI has just been all about
the product just about making the best
conversational AI platform that they
could
um and as a byproduct of that not a lot
of people knew about onereach AI so I
think all of a sudden seeing us pretty
much as the highest ranked platform on
this report
was very exciting for us but also very
eye-opening for the industry uh and a
lot of that is kind of rooted in Rob's
approach to this technology which is
it's all about having a platform that's
that's open and flexible
I love it I'm not sure if I answered
your question that was a lot of talking
I just did so
it was a it was a very cool story so
I'll take it
um
and it sounds like a I just had a few
just comments on the leadership you just
described I think it was it's sort of a
I think just shows a little bit on the
type of leader he is and um type of
people that you surround yourself with
which is really cool and and I just love
their conversation on on storytelling
and and how that fits in also with
conversational Ai and in the book that
you wrote and I want to thank you for
your time this was an awesome uh short
but meaningful conversation and I and I
I really appreciate the insights and the
energy I'm taking with me this idea of a
passion as a driving vehicle for
Effective storytelling I think you know
you mentioned that there are some things
that you know you can learn perhaps some
things that maybe are more coming
naturally but I think you know choosing
to talk about things that you're
passionate about and me and and being
intentional about about being passionate
about them and discovering those
passions I think that's probably a good
way to start it at least for people who
want to become better storytellers is to
talk about things that the things that
they're passionate about so Josh thank
you very much for your time and and
continue doing amazing work with one
reach Ai and everything else you're
doing I'm sure there's many more
experiences that I'm going to be
cheering from the side so thank you very
much
thank you Michael it's been a pleasure
thank you
foreign